miley is that just an excuse for me to
do an impression of you on the show and
she was like
hell yeah i'm miley cyrus
hell yeah she's miley cyrus and she
approves of this monologue after selena
gomez pulled out that pretty spot-on
impersonation of her fellow disney star
on saturday night live it was so awesome
miley gave it her stamp of approval on
instagram sporting this shirt in a
series of selfies emblazoned with what
might just be miley's new catchphrase
hell yeah i'm miley cyrus
i also asked one of my oldest friends
miley cyrus
and she said
just be yourself and have
fun i was like miley is that just an
excuse for me to do an impression of you
on the show and she was like
hell yeah i'm miley cyrus
not only did miley approve but so did
some snl vets
how did you think i did i i thought you
had delivered the comedy so beautifully
and so
low-key but hilarious i really thought
have you ever wanted me to do something
like that no i don't think you'd be good
at it
yeah those guys just so happen to
co-star with selena in hulu's only
murders in the building i think we
should just hit him with the charm good
excellent so i'll take the lead on this
excuse me but back to miley it makes
sense selena would turn to the singer
for advice she's basically an honorary
cast member at this point having
appeared as a host and musical guest a
few times plus countless cameos over the
years i must have smoked too much
cigarettes
i'm totally here i promise well
okay if you're really the old me then
what do i say every single morning when
i wake up
oh my god it is like totally the morning
and the birds are chirping and stuff
like that and i'm like super hungry and
stuff like that and i am obsessed with
cereal
and she's got nothing but thanks for snl
executive producer lauren michaels for
giving her shot after shot after shot on
the show lauren has been my hero since
the first time i did snl when i was 18.
yeah i'm gonna be 30 by the time we're
doing new year so i've been working with
him for the last 12 years and you're
somebody he would be drawn to naturally
because you are i'll do anything and
i'll make an ass of myself there you go
miley just locked in her next gig with
lauren coming back for another new
year's eve show on nbc now it seems like
i kind of know what i'm doing on new
year's forever that's really nice which
i like so i know
that i have to keep my act together
enough
to make it to new year's yeah and that
nbc will actually allow me to be on
television because there was a couple
years there where it was dicey
[Music]